but that type of integrity or both in
three-point play for Durant Warriors 9
for 9 from the field here on the third
nice pass beautifully done by Green
Williams kept alive here's Williams with
the layup
finally in this Quintin cook rims out on
the quarter jump they'd hit their
previous nine shots here in the third
who set a new franchise record
incidentally for most points in a
playoff game for the Huntington at 45 at
all the NBA record is 157 points Temari
bent by Fremont Green now by Jordan Bell
on a switch Guevara got us on our bank
gets attached
[Applause]
is dropping in the wing jumper I do and
I agree with the relevant I do because I
agree is old-fashioned basketball
elections he's going to the parks you
play against each other like she wanted
to be competitive his great knocks one
down when I asked him about watching his
own game take back outside of the
emotions of the game we said he sees
passion the guy he'd like to have on his
own team he call himself a warrior voice
Capri
fires it down the same by girl on green
ends up in the hands of Wilson Cantrell
the cleverest wild shot meds here what
happens on a stop and then who Williams
he keeps his eyes on his open teammate
in the recipient of the shot the corner
this time no people beautiful pledges to
turn off picked it off tilt this
Alexander sets it up for the Clippers
out score the Warriors 3114 from last
seven-and-a-half cutters
in the warrior shoot is 61% and the
Clippers at 50 if they win because he's
gonna want to sure up some things you
cannot feel bad habits especially keep
turning it over Alexander called for the
personal right there look at his days
playing with the Hawks Watson played
deep this on Isaiah Thomas and others
he's always been passionate in his game
high school fire Lou Williams played by
Andre Iguodala got the step and a
beautiful setup Pajero
orders but they struggle that's usually
the reason Williams off balance but it's
tipped home by Harold you don't want to
give anything they still get to go home
and Wow
the steal by Beverly took it away from
curry and government does the rest that
Steve Kerr very upset late Thompson is
back out the floor Williams Pajero for
Ghana very funnel Thompson Durant and
curry clip is doing a good job
Donal re for free yes
hurry about 7 of 14 from the field
Harold the morale and scores
a piece of turn three mark green on that
last foul by Goldschmidt
there's Williams on the drive and a foul
the collective heart and soul of the
Clippers one of the best at driving and
getting files in and this is what I mean
you just have to at some point get back
to playing your game listening to coach
Doc Rivers coach 120 my dream cuts one
that's the step rebound
how did he get that he's back in it just
sit on the side and chair no time for
technicals on the side
they can't go to the stage a six-point
lead
whatever is off balance scores
funky butt over here Lou wins so smooth
the hang time and I tell you what under
three to go before the rat late by he'll
go we're not a crossover it's why it's
so hard to stop five four seven ten from
11 from the free-throw line
five assists 20 points a heck of a
crossover and finished now to to 20
remaining and before Gilders Alexander
gets up to he'll punch it down it's
about the two habits that you said it
right now with the turnovers he's not
happy with the Warriors places Roy
Williams sit down on the game is tied it
welcome back to go things we got a great
when Louise these hottie 12 but 21 come
up on a minute luteus come on poor girl
and there's curry curry he's going to
give it up coach Doc Rivers is mad about
that push off curry says so what get the
rebound out of the net buddy that's 31
his weirdness puts on the works and
score Williams
current
[Applause]
and open the shot
[Applause]
mostly public covers since it was 12:11
and on the other end
how about Sam it killed this Alexander
finds him as a fan I'm thinking wait a
minute keep it in Lou's hand keep it a
lose hand but hey
the first one in
[Applause]
and he made it and thirty-one won't
leave my gold estate this made it yes
Thompson has a fire up of three with
that matter and that will do it
the LA Clippers of the Warriors court
here at Oregon down by as any us warning